that I was talking about in the last
couple of videos okay uh to me it was
clear that was that's why in yesterday
video I was you know still talking about
this because you can see price is you
know testing so many times the 150 main
does this purple line over here and it
doesn't really push price lower okay
because if this was really bad it's and
it's pushing press logo you would see
something like this okay it may end us
your 50ma and you would see price you
know making new lows making new lows and
it didn't really happen okay here you
got some kind of a drop
here but then you can see price
recovering and again it's you know
testing the 150 Ma so this is when you
know that the Trap is being set
and there is a short squeeze in common
because the retail Trader sees this
chart and says okay the 150 amazing
resistance what I'm gonna do well I'm
Gonna Keep placing my shorts here okay
short short short all the time so that
in one of these attempts the market
maker is going to push price higher
there was also a lot of Liquidations in
high block capital
but when I got through them in a second
that also helped us to justify the idea
of the short squeeze and also the dxy
okay the dxy was moving very
aggressively to the upside yesterday and
Bitcoin was not going down they hold
this Zone look like this that's what
Bitcoin did yesterday okay Bitcoin was
you know simply holding this on while
the dxy and the dollar Index was making
another information and we were in this
leg up here okay so that was another
idea that was showing you that Bitcoin
had some strength a Bitcoin didn't want
to go down and that's because they had
this this trap
in mind okay this short squeeze
now uh we're gonna go through capital in
a minute well I'm going to talk a bit
more about the chart uh I've just taken
my profits okay well I just posted on
Twitter uh my entry was right before bed
last time it was around here uh three
thousand sorry thirty thousand twenty I
just closed the trade because we are
very close to the mid-range okay that's
my first Target uh well to be honest
what I've done I'm gonna go through in a
minute but after the position here
because first that's the mid-range super
resistant let me show you
okay you can see how it's a level there
you can see all of the spikes check this
is getting tested here all the time
all the time you know I don't want
something like this over here
happening to me okay that's what you
know I take advantage of this move here
I close it that's my idea now
the other idea is because if we went to
the one out into the one hour time frame
sorry
you can see here how this pump was
building the Asian session okay at least
part of this pump this candle that
leaves a liquidity pool behind okay that
candle was the rendition session
um then also this one here as well okay
now this part here
is London so let's see what happens bro
you have to be cautious here
okay because if you've had Asia pumping
okay so let me let me Mark it for you if
you go Asia pumping like this okay
and
London
I mean it pushed also okay by my London
let me fix this box
okay imagine
okay and it closes in this level over
here then you can expect that this Asian
pump is about to get retraced okay
um that would be either during the New
York session
okay or during the next Asian session
but for that you need to see London
holding here okay if London keeps
pushing higher then you have you know AC
pumping London pumping
you know that makes New York even more
interesting because you know there's a
possibility that they keep pushing
higher but that's the idea so keep an
eye on London let's see what they do if
they close this their London session
sorry
around 30 200 okay and that will be
around 2 p.m UTC time then be careful uh
during the New York session because they
might you know don't price lower
um so that's you know then I say that I
was shooting for this week this week I
will suspect him to be honest I was
wrong about this thing okay because I
posted in the Sunday that I was
expecting this week to be a nice week
for trading and I was terribly wrong
terribly wrong okay it's been a
nightmare
for anybody Trading ankens uh probably
you have enjoyed but for me that I'm
trading Bitcoin mostly
uh you know it was a game of patience it
was a game of patience okay to see when
I opened my position and when this sort
of discrete was gonna happen but anyway
be careful uh because you have here the
mid-range resistance you have this pump
here during the sensation okay this
candle I don't like it but at the same
time if you're going to the forward time
frame there is something
that could be pretty good okay check
this out 4.50ma okay I think that if we
hold
above this 50 I mean the four hour time
frame there is possibility for more
website
okay and with more upset I mean you know
to retrace
this liquidity pool for example here
okay and that will take you to 30 700
okay so I mean it's not looking
too bad but you have to be careful
because when Asia pumps you know that's
a course of concern for me and also you
have here the mid-range resistance so
yeah guys uh if you took this straight
uh consider taking profit soon okay
again it's not Financial advice I'm just
telling you how I'm playing this
okay and then you know if Bitcoin is
again consolidating here
above the 4 or 50ma maybe I'll retake
that long
okay but for now you know happy with my
uh with this day trade that I took here
okay that's good profits for me so I
don't have any reason to hold the trade
you know expecting higher prices when I
have an Asia pumped I'll have here the
mid-range because then I'll have the
risk of price you know doing a round
trip and going back to Miami
okay but anyway uh let's go now to high
block Capital let's check the liquidity
we're here in hablo capital in the
liquidation level check this out okay at
the bottom this is the Delta so you can
see all of these red they are basically
a cumulative liquidation levels from
short positions that's what I was
telling you guys be ready because we
might see a shorter squeeze this even
got to 10 billion dollars
so it actually was 12 billion dollars
worth of short requestations the other
day that was two days ago so I was
telling you guys shortage quiz might be
coming and now you can see that the
Delta has gone back to zero after this
pump that's telling you that all those
shorts have been liquidated okay and
also you have here one beautiful Spike
check out the right of this chart okay
that Spike that basically is 30
600 dollars okay so that's uh along the
Target that you can keep in mind this
would match pretty much with the
liquidity pool that I showed in the one
hour time frame but for that first you
need to see you know the 4r50ma holding
maybe that's after the asymptom gets
retraced okay so I don't know how long
this might take this might take I'll be
more time
um now in the liquidation heat map if we
get there
but when I sit here in the 12 hours time
frame I imagine this chart to look like
a mess right now uh yeah
it is too much liquidity everywhere in
12 hours okay but at the same this time
frame wow look at that that's a lot of
liquidity there too okay let me check
this out
okay this is very interesting uh this is
basically telling you that with this
sideways move okay they were forcing
traders to open shorts okay that's why
you know I mean it's quite normal
because if you notice you know we'll
wear all the time below 30k so then the
retail Trader must be thinking hey you
know if we are below 30k
that's basically telling you
the Bitcoin is looking quite weak you
know and also we are at the rain slow so
you know the right cow to the downside
is in a minute that's how the retail
Trader thinks that's why they do
consolidation Spike down Spike up Spike
down Spike up in the range lows so they
can open shorts and now you can see all
the swords are stuck here okay these are
the liquidations okay so now you have
the shorter squeeze and if everything
goes well the market making is gonna
start to hit these zones over here okay
again 30 750 You Got It Bad in the chart
okay that's the liquidity pull in the
one hour time frame
as I told you guys this moves sometimes
it takes time to to play out well that's
usually because the market making is
trying to build all those liquidations
first okay so then when they move price
up or down they are gonna hit more more
liquidations and it's gonna be a more
effective move okay but then don't
dismiss here 29 200 there's also some
liquidity there okay and that's uh once
we break out to the downside of this
range which I still think it's gonna
happen okay
I might be wrong with this one but I was
telling you I'm expecting one last short
squeeze I think that that's what we are
currently saying now okay and then if
everything goes well
I think that they that the key date in
the calendar is gonna be next week with
the fomc meeting okay that's when
everything can unfold and maybe that's
why that's when we can break out of this
range but for now all of this this short
excuse is just a liquidity game okay a
short squeeze to stop all those swords
that have piled up in this Zone here
okay uh so that's basically what I'm
saying guys uh be very careful if you
have taken this
um this long over here
congratulations don't forget to take
profits because you have a put in the
rendition session that if London closed
the session at 2 pm UTC time at 30 200
so basically if they hold today then you
could expect New York to dump and
retrace the Asian pump or if New York
doesn't do that then Asia might do it
themselves tonight
okay guys
uh I still you can see that there is a
lot more glue to the upside down to the
downside at least for now so you know
even if they retrace the ice and boom we
are probably gonna look into more uh
lungs okay because yeah there is still a
lot of liquidity all right uh so that's
pretty much everything guys that's
everything I have to say regarding
Bitcoin before I finish the video and
say goodbye to you guys I wanted to say
that if you support the content of
course you can give a like a comment
subscribe that's good for the algorithm
so the video shows to other users in
YouTube but also of course you can
register with the referral Link in the
description immediate okay it's an
exchange that doesn't require kyc unless
if you are in the US uh Canada or
Singapore I think I do get five dollar
bonus when you log in also if you
deposit at least a hundred dollars
they're gonna participate in the next
giveaways of the trading course also
um deposits over 200 get 10 payback that
means like you for example
uh deposit let's say 500 then you're
gonna get fifty dollars back and of
course you know if the if you deposit
bigger amounts then you get bigger
rewards okay bigger pay bigger paid
backs all right so anyway guys thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
soon